one of my favorite people i'm smoking
him a long time cause he's too busy he's
traveling the world being busy too the
spine of night is available in theaters
digital and on demand this friday
october 29th an animated fantasy horror
film just in time
for halloween
and joining us here on the rich eisen
show is joe manganiello on the
mercedes-benz van phone line how are you
joe
i'm doing well i just got the tail end
of that so you know my last high school
football game was against montana's high
school and uh and you were there to
witness i wonder if this is what you're
talking about this is witnessed my
touchdowns yes catch from jomon we just
played that moment from your one of your
many previous appearances on the show
getting ready for you to call in right
now are you are you in ireland still
right now joe are you still over there
yeah i'm i'm in dublin ireland hence my
inability to watch the clip
yeah i'm here i've been here for been
here for two months yep um and i've got
another month or two left in my tour of
duty okay so
are you staying up till like you know
all ends of the night sometimes watching
the steelers you steelers in seahawks
that game probably was going on
around two in the morning your time
right did you catch that one you stay up
uh
that was uh except uh my my wife sophia
came to visit me i'm over here shooting
am a new amc sci-fi series called
moonhaven she came over to visit me and
i took her into the
um
wild highlands of west court and while
we were there
i couldn't watch it but the nfl this
year really got it together with this
game pass system and i knew that as soon
as i woke up if i just ignored
all
semblance of culture my phone that i
could watch the game in peace without
commercials the next day
but i'm on a thread with a bunch of old
pittsburgh steeler fans so of course i
woke up and had 54 messages and just had
to like sift through them
so here you are your way your wife's
coming over
and you're in this beautiful spot on
planet earth and and you still you still
gain past it when you woke up in the
morning joe that actually happened
of course you committed a horse you're
coming out of course it's just this is
how we're there this is the life when
you're born into pittsburgh rich hashtag
here we go so what do you what do you
think what do you make of your team
six games in seven weeks so on so forth
coming off the buy what do you think joe
look
you know here well here's the thing
and this is a similar situation that we
found ourselves in early this season to
what happened
last season towards the that's about
three quarters of the way through
um what happens is that once you have
enough
starters missing on defense you have
enough injuries you know last year i was
confident if we took the field with that
defense healthy we could be in any game
we wanted to be
and once you start losing all those
pieces once you know last year devin
bush went down
uh bud dupree went down we started
having injuries in the secondary all of
a sudden you've got you know you you've
got guys who aren't starters playing
in a lot of slots on d and the same
thing happened right out of the gate you
know week one we take down the bills
all of a sudden all the naysayers are
scratching their head going wow maybe we
were wrong
and yeah i think they were wrong to
count out the steelers d and how tough
it was but once you have 8 000 groin
injuries
uh let alone all the other injuries that
were going on i mean the steelers need
to fire their groin coach whoever that
is going on over there but uh
once you have like five five guys go
down four with groin injuries it's like
what is happening and uh and then stuff
on to it obviously being out of the
lineup typhoon alawalu being out of the
lineup you know we can't you know clone
cam hayward into three separate people
this quickly i mean we need to call jeff
bezos and get that going for i don't
know another 20 20 23 years i think
we're good um but we're not ready yet so
you know i just think we're in a
situation once again like last year
where um the defense was the strength of
this team at least while our young
offensive line of young offense gelled
and um
they just couldn't buy us that time
because of those injuries and then you
know you go through you know we're going
through these these growing pains now
that now we're very obvious because
they're not shielded by the defense did
you say growing pains are growing
growing pains i i don't know which one
did you say okay
so
one thing that they should do is i mean
just just put naji harris in bubble wrap
man that's the guy to me that's the guy
i know we're talking defense
that's it he's the difference maker
um and and i even brought this up to the
great jerome bettis last week i called
him the most valuable steeler even with
tj watt on the roster
because even though tj did what he did
i know it is and that's why i'm bringing
it up to you i mean tj as we know in
that overtime gaming in seattle um that
you were game passing um ended the first
drive with a sack and then ended the
game with a sack fumble and that's what
the steelers needed but they wouldn't
even have been positioned to win that
game if it's not for naji harris he
keeps ben clean he keeps ben uh
he keeps him clean because not only is
ben not winging it 50 times but you have
to respect naji harris coming out of the
backfield and also hitting you
in the mouth um so
you know you can't you can't just pin
your ears back and go for ben and just
keep all your defenders you know three
yards in the line of scrimmage because
claypool might actually beat you deep
with a play action like naji harris is
the guy that's the guy gotta bubble wrap
him joe
no i i agree i i think naj is so
fantastic and you know you you felt bad
him stepping into a situation with as
many young and inexperienced linemen
um as he was um
yeah he just felt bad for the kid
because you could just see the
brilliance
and um then we want to
obviously like keep that guy happy
because i i really think that that guy
could be the future of the team i think
he's really he's just an incredible and
he's such he's a really great guy you
talk about character in terms of the
steelers and and how we like to play
football or how we like to play our you
know off the field and he's got all
those off the field uh intangibles but
you know obviously the off the field
stuff doesn't want to win the game but
um you know having a great guy in the
locker room and having a great guy in
the community is something that uh
you know it means something to people in
pittsburgh you want to root for your
players you know joe manganiello here on
the rich eisen show um his film the
spine of night will be available in
theaters digital and demand this coming
friday and time for halloween we'll talk
about that in a second two items that
have happened uh since you've left the
country joe um
first one uh the bengals have gotten on
back there the bengals have gotten good
joe the bengals have gotten real good
the bengals have gotten first overall
current top seed in the afc good joe are
you aware that yeah they have a good
quote they have a good quarterback okay
they finally figured it out i mean uh
they found uh they found andy dalton's
successor rich finally no
see that's the back of the joe mangano
hand right there
uh-huh i saw it i knew i knew i just had
to scratch the surface i'm just
mentioning how good the bengals are i
knew it i knew it didn't take no listen
man i mean it's you know we're not i
mean you can't get angry it's like um
you know it's it's like for years all of
the you know the rivalry this afc north
rivalry and it's like rivalry they have
to win in order for it to be a rivalry
um and i'm not talking like bronte's
birthday pacman jones you know
you're uh i'm talking about like you
know actually like win consistently um
but i think joe burrow is a great
quarterback um and i think it makes the
decision i think it makes the division
uh more interesting i you know i think
we all like the challenge and um
yeah i think it's i think it's just good
for business when other teams wind up um
finally stepping up and and and becoming
good i mean we'll see if we should make
a winner playoff game okay
second thing here joe uh just happened
in the last 48 hours uh mike tomlin's
name wound up on the usc
coaching wish list did you see
over there in ireland mike tomlin's
response did you see it did you hear it
oh i i sure did yeah he was wound up on
their list via carson palmer speaking of
usc connections to the cincinnati
bengals um yeah and we all saw how that
how his response went from jeez how'd
you like that one how'd you like it
how'd you like it
you know
i i um
you know i i miss the old you know
playoffs
[Music]
i speak for you know practice yeah i i
think we like you know we kind of we
love those post-game interviews
you know especially by coaches there's
that great series of beer commercials
that had
you know all those little clips and mike
tomlin is
when he's on
there's nobody better in the league
right now i mean you could talk
belichick for his smugness and
interviews as like for comedic
which i mean by the way
like
did he pull matt jones aside
and say hey
you're going to talk like me in every
press conference or they just do it just
mac jones took it upon himself to kind
of kiss up with a coach and like watch
this you know like i don't know but he's
a great mimic and i think that you know
he's probably got a good future in
impersonations but you know other than
that i mean mike tomlin's like such a
great interview and um you know i'm on a
thread a steelers thread with some guys
i played football with when i was
younger and guys from pittsburgh who
have kind of scattered throughout the
country and we all stay in touch by
texting each other through the week and
you know draft day and all that kind of
stuff and um we all speak to each other
at times in communism so uh this is this
is gonna be another great one well i
mean i gotta tell you jokes we're gonna
be sifting through the speech yeah i
mean we we we
cut up sound bites and uses what we call
in this radio business drops you just
heard the playoffs one that mike deltufo
has and we got this one now from tomlin
this is it never say never but never
that's it right there that's it
that's it
you know and uh that's it right there
that nature that's another commoner yeah
yeah never say never but never i mean
that is just phenomenal i mean
i i i don't have time for this that's
right and then and then you know and and
i totally understand that his outrage
and so just to put a button on it are
you implying that carson palmer is
throwing that name out there and putting
that stone in the steeler
pawn to ripple effect because he's a
bengal did you imply that well moments
ago what joe well here well here's the
thing i wanted to ask you guys like
sabotage
what tomlin said at the end was tomlin
says at the end of his response why
aren't they talking about
andy reid or champagne why aren't they
talking about sean payton why me
and and that
there is where the noir detective the
rich eisen the war detective show
kicks off why rich and now it's you and
your trench coat out at night with susie
playing the femme fatale
find out why
and get to the bottom of this
well i mean because carson palmer didn't
mention sean payton and andy reid thus
your implication that he's mentioning
tomlin because he wants to screw at the
steelers even though
let's be honest if you're making up a
wish list for coaches why wouldn't you
want to have mike tomlin on the list
right
why wouldn't you want him carson palmer
carson palmer has something to do with
it and episode one of the rich eyes and
film noir
andy dalton is sitting there in chicago
watching justin fields just get sacked
uh joe manganiello here on the rich
hudson show yes
right uh so the spine of night what what
what's uh what do you want folks to know
about this as we're getting set for
halloween this is good
scare fare just in time for the weekend
joe
yeah okay um if you like
if you like a little
fantasy with your
uh with your psychedelics and okay come
to the right place um it's it's a
psychedelic rotoscoped um and for people
that don't know what rotoscope animation
is it's uh it was a very like
short-lived kind of animation style in
which they would film real actors and
then like painstakingly hand paint over
each frame so like uh um ralph bakshi
with like fire and ice wizards uh the
old lord of the rings you know frank
frazetta you know it's like heavy metal
for people that like the old heavy metal
movie it falls right into that category
in that lineage but it's also like a
real breath of fresh air it's uh it's
ultra violent um to the point of like
craziness and kind of like
chuckling like belly laughing you know
like i mean it's wild and it's out there
and the characters are nuts the story is
great
um it's poignant i watched it with
sophia fully expecting her to stop
paying attention five minutes in and she
loved it and stayed with it the whole
time and thought it was fantastic
um and i just think that um for the for
the crowd that has fallen in love with
game of thrones
this is like
right in that wheelhouse if you love
game of thrones you love lord of the
rings
you're going to love this movie it's a
great halloween watch well i mean you're
in it richard e grant lucy lawless
patton oswalt just to name a few but the
ultimate i think
uh check mark definitely comes from your
wife when sophia liked it and liked it
so much because she refers to you and
your friends who play dungeons and
dragons as nerds right like she refers
to you as the nerds correct so
well i prefer i prefer intellectual
uh
i prefer the nerds are playing
yes so
because this seems like you're getting
the nerd who what nerds how many nerds
were the captain of the football team
the captain of the basketball team i'm
involved with you know how many what i
mean i prefer intellectual well-rounded
you're as multi-dimensional as your
20-sided die joe i get it i totally get
it
so you're making you're making your dnd
you mixed your dnd stuff with your with
your work
look at you man you're just living the
life well yeah i mean that was that was
the whole thing you know i i've actually
you know i i worked for dungeons and
dragons for six seven years so you know
why uh why just play the game when you
can do the job you wanted as a kid in
fact now that we're on it now that you
brought it up uh when are you coming
over to roll up your character rich when
are you going to jump into a game well
joe all you have to do is invite me and
i'm i'm all the way in joe you got it
i'm i'm in gosh seriously rich i'm
serious we're gonna get we're gonna as
soon as i get home when are you when are
you getting home yeah
i think you'd love it when are you
getting home uh yeah i'll be home wow
that's uh that's debatable we're i'm
waiting for the final schedule tomorrow
it's kind of been like a holding pattern
but no but it's because you know a few
more episodes of film and then you know
how it works in los angeles certainly if
somebody's not gonna be around for two
months three months you're like
absolutely we'll get together like
that's the way it works here you know
how i know you've been away a while but
not you know that's the way it works
here like absolutely let's get together
when i know it's not possible okay yeah
i'm
i'm i'm not an la guy okay i didn't grow
up rooting for the la lakers okay my
parents were from boston i wrote it for
the celtics that's what side of that
whole thing i was on okay so you know i
live in l.a but it's not really home for
me i'm a pittsburgh boy so when i say it
i mean it okay i'll have you over to the
dungeon okay and uh susie and susie and
sophia can hang out
upstairs and uh and we'll
we'll we'll get down we'll also dice
okay it'll be it'll be great you just
let me know i'm totally up for it um so
uh before i let you go joe uh couldn't
help but notice on your instagram feed
quite a bit uh all these lovely
photographs from from ireland uh you've
got bubbles a dog with you um and
bubbles is in your left arm or right arm
everywhere
everywhere is uh how's bubbles doing
joe tell me how bubbles the dog is
bubbles is great you know bubbles
doesn't like anyone but me i mean she
likes sophia like but but like the whole
time she's with sophia she's looking at
the door waiting for me to come home
mm-hmm like to always pick one person
and i i didn't want you know i didn't
want a dog man that was not i traveled
to my i just didn't want i never had
sophia got this dog but the dog
the dog picked me
and it's just been the greatest friend i
could ever have i travel the world with
this dog
i climb up mountain sides and take her
to go see castles in rural ireland i put
her on the plane when she flies around
with me i take her to work she's like
our unofficial mascot on moonhaven i
mean i i love this thing it's the best
she comes to the gym with me she sits in
my gym bag she takes a nap kind of
watches me work out we're seeing her
look at a steak that's right it's sliced
up and each slice is this big bigger
than the dog joe like literally the dog
is the size of a football you hold her
with all four points of pressure it's
impressive um so um i i just love seeing
you as this big big dude big hulking man
and this little dog this little little
dog it's quite a it's quite a
companionship you've got going joe i
love it i do who wouldn't who would have
thought it would have gone this way rich
i never saw it happening this way but
you know now that it has it makes total
sense to me
it's great uh sophia gets jealous though
because uh you know the dog just loves
me
and the joke the joke always is that
like when i landed in dublin and the dog
ran around my apartment and i had rented
and she ran in every room and then came
back to me and like the joke was
you finally got rid of her
that's finally the two of us can be
alone
and then when she came to visit the joke
was like oh my god i thought she was
gone
get this woman away
oh my god what are you doing we just got
rid of her i thought we watched her now
she found us get rid of her right
actually i think i i i mean it is
amazing certainly since we have an
exclusive uh mike deltufo exclusive
soundbite of what joe said when when you
first got bubbles right you hit never
say never but never and then now look at
you now look at you now you know
look at you now jill seriously that was
it so i mean if you're trying to
insinuate that mike thoman is secretly
vying for the ufc job
and that metaphor no um i don't know if
that's gonna hold water i am not what's
true for me don't say never but i never
want a dog i got it i love it i know
that and and just to put a button on
this whole conversation you know because
uh i'm sure you're not terribly attuned
to the rich eisen show over there in
ireland despite being a fan i'm sure um
i said that there's no the one reason
why a pro coach would go to college
one okay is because when you go to
college and you win you have tenure like
you're never ever gonna have to worry
about getting fired
he's got that one job in the nfl where
it's the same exact thing
like why why would he ever
he doesn't have to he he could he is a
coach and a leader of men not a guy who
goes into the living room of an 18 year
old and says will you play for me like
that's like it makes zero
sense zero sense that's what i said so
just to be yeah yeah i i think you know
he was right in in his praise of the
organization or at least his
saying that he had the best coaching job
in the nfl um i i have to agree with
that from a coach's point of view that
that has got to be the best work for the
steelers in the learning family okay so
uh just to recap uh
everybody should go see the spine of
night
uh available in theaters digital and on
demand this friday um bubble's the dog
loves you and can't wait for sofia to
leave the room um and also
um you're you're still very optimistic
about your steelers season and lastly
can't wait to be dungeons and dragons
friends with you that'll be great
just let me know when you're back rich
i can't wait
and i believe that take care of yourself
joe safe travels enjoy the rest of your
stay there in on in ireland you'll be
well let's chat soon thanks rich sophia
and i miss you and susie so let's get
together as soon as i get back right
back at you man we'll do it at joe
manganiello on twitter and instagram the
one and only joseph manganiello
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here